[Musique]
bonsoir jeudi 28 mai bienvenue dans le
journal de tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité locale
une prise de parole en fin d'après midi
le premier ministre edouard philippe a
précisé les mesures de l'acte 2 du
déconfinement que retenir des annonces
et quelles conséquences dans les
yvelines
le point dans cette édition ils avaient
jusqu'à aujourd'hui pour le faire les
élus désignés au premier tour des
municipales sont installés lors d'un
premier conseil avant magny les hameaux
ce soir c'était à elancourt qu'une
séance se déroulait hier jean michel
fourgous a été officiellement reconduit
pour un cinquième mandat de maire dans
la ville et puis pas de public présent
sur place mais ça ne lui empêchera pas
de se tenir même cette année le 16e
maisons laffitte jazz festival se
déroulera bien du 12 au 21 juin une
édition particulière au vu du contexte
qui sera en version digitale
son discours était très attendu le
premier ministre edouard philippe a
présenté en fin d'après-midi la phase 2
du déconfinement zone verte réouverture
des bars et restaurants ou encore règle
des 100 km on fait le point sur les
principales annonces avec au rayon
l'épidémie giacobbi 19 ralenti les
résultats sont bons sur le plan
sanitaire conséquence il n'y a désormais
plus de départements en rouge sur la
carte de france
seul notre région l'île de france et en
orange
alors première bonne nouvelle et bien
dès ce week-end le public pourra de
nouveau accéder aux parcs et aux jardins
franciliens concernant vos déplacements
dès le 2 juin la règle des 100 km est
supprimée sur le territoire français
dans le secteur de l'éducation
maintenant 100% des écoles maternelles
et primaires ouvriront progressivement
dès mardi 2 juin l'ensemble des collèges
va rouvrir y compris dans les yvelines
qui est donc en zone orange avec dans un
premier temps elle les sixièmes et les
cinquièmes pour les lycées yvelinois la
priorité sera donnée aux établissements
professionnels et notamment aux élèves
qui doivent passer une certification
pour les lycées généraux il y aura des
convocations individuelles
enfin informations importantes elles
épreuves orales du bac de français est
annulé elle sera validée en contrôle
continu
concernant maintenant elle les bars les
cafés les restaurants
pourront rouvrir en zone verte et les
yvelines et en zone orange seuls les
terrasses seront autorisés à rouvrir dès
le 2 juin elle le 2 juin tous les musées
et monuments ouvriront également sur
l'ensemble du territoire pour les parcs
de loisirs les salles de spectacle et
les piscines ou encore les salles de
théâtre et bien il faudra attendre le 22
juin dans les yvelines pour qu'il rouvre
les cinémas euros environ leurs portes
le 22 juin
mais ça ce sera sur l'ensemble du
territoire même date également 22 juin
pour l'ouverture des campings yvelinois
reste interdit les événements culturels
et sportifs dans l'espace public
l'ouverture des discothèques les stades
les hippodromes ou encore les salles de
jeux enfin un nouveau point sera fait
justement aux alentours du 22 juin pour
la phase iii du déconfinement voilà pour
cet acte ii du déconfinement en
ile-de-france et dans les yvelines le
département qui a enregistré deux
victimes supplémentaires de lakovic 19
entre mardi et mercredi
489 personnes sont décédées dans les
hôpitaux du territoire le nombre
d'hospitalisations est lui en légère
baisse 592 patients étaient hospitalisés
hier dans les yvelines 37 en réanimation
statistiques également en diminution et
depuis le début de cette crise sanitaire
1870 personnes ont été guéries après un
passage à l'hôpital dans le département
et c'est sans doute l'une des
conséquences directes de cette crise
sanitaire et du confinement qui en a
résulté le nombre de chômeurs a
considérablement augmenté au mois
d'avril +10 7% dans les yvelines en un
mois pour la catégorie à
oh ce record sensiblement sur la même
tendance qu'au niveau national où
l'augmentation est de 22 6% toutes
catégories confondues les yvelines n'ont
jamais compté autant de demandeurs
d'emploi depuis 1996 ils étaient cent
onze 1540 le mois dernier je vous
parlais il ya un instant de l'acte 2 du
déconfinement c'est aussi l acte 1 de la
relance qui a été présentée aujourd'hui
par la région ile-de-france la
présidente de la collectivité
valérie pécresse a annoncé plus d'un
milliard d'euros pour cette enveloppe
plusieurs politiques sont concernés
l'économie la solidarité l'éducation et
l'environnement les détails de nicolas
d'ombré
c'est l'acteur 1 du plan de relance
régional d'ile-de-france premiers axes
de ce programme l'économie avec des
aides aux entreprises et la lutte contre
le chômage une enveloppe de 870 millions
d'euros 500 millions d'euros vont être
consacrés aux prêts et aux fonds de
soutien aux tpe pme commerçants et
indépendants en difficulté les filières
francilienne stratégie comme
l'agriculture l'automobile
l'aéronautique ou la construction vont
être soutenus à hauteur de 75 millions
d'euros
tout comme la culture et le tourisme la
lutte contre le chômage passera par de
nouvelles places de formation attribués
aux demandeurs d'emploi dans les
secteurs en tension
le financement des formations
individuelles sera renforcée deuxième
axe est la solidarité et l'éducation 97
millions d'euros consacrés au pouvoir
d'achat des lycéens et des plus
vulnérables
la région s'est engagée aussi à
organiser des campus d'été
le principe ouvrir les lycées durant les
deux dernières semaines du mois d'août
pour une remise à niveau des fonds sont
aussi débloqués pour les familles
défavorisées pour la période estivale 50
millions d'euros seront consacrés au
secteur de la santé avec notamment 18
mille étudiants infirmiers et aides
soignants rémunérés pour leurs activités
pendant la crise enfin la relance passe
aussi par la transition environnementale
238 millions d'euros consacrés à un
budget participatif environnementale
destinés à des projets publics ou encore
au développement de transports
écologiques et au rer vélo puis le
déploiement de bornes publiques de
recharge dans l'actualité également la
visite de franck riester ce matin dans
les yvelines le ministre de la culture
s'est rendu au château de breteuil à
choisel il fait partie de ces petits
musées autorisée à rouvrir
depuis la phase 1 du déconfinement le
château de breteuil accueille de nouveau
du public depuis le 15 mai une
signalétique spéciale pour les gars de
saint quentin en yvelines
l'agglomération les fait installer en ce
moment pour faciliter l'usagé des
transports en commun dans ces lieux de
grand passage 1300 lignes seront tracées
en tout sur le territoire par une
entreprise locale basée à trappes
le traçage a débuté hier mercredi à la
gare de saint quentin en yvelines à
montigny le bretonneux et s'est terminée
au petit matin
installation de pochoirs pour des
marquages au sol en extérieur
les âges adhésif en intérieur une
soixantaine de stickers marouflé elle
les salariés de l'entreprise trappistes
recommence l'exercice dès ce soir dans
une autre gare du territoire lui et
président sortant de saint quentin en
yvelines jean michel fourgous repart
pour un nouveau mandat et l'encours il a
été officiellement élue hier lors du
conseil municipal d'installation de la
commune suite à sa victoire aux
élections le 15 mars dernier une séance
à huis clos en raison du contexte
sanitaire et retransmise sur internet
manon varaldo et nicolas landry pour le
sujet espace entre chaque personne port
du masque le conseil municipal
d'installation d'elancourt était
différent cette crise sanitaire a
provoqué des changements
un nouveau monde se prépare c'est une
refonte des méthodes de travail
une enfant de des méthodes de
concertation l'impact sur l'organisation
du travail sur l'éducation sur la
sécurité sur sur le pib comment produire
sur la façon de travailler tous ensemble
il ya une plus grande concertation
mondiale qu'on a vu aussi regarder les
scientifiques les médecins qui ont
travaillé en trois mois ils ont ils ont
commencé vraiment à cerner le virus ben
ouais c'est vraiment un monde nouveau
quelque part qui est né un nouveau monde
d'imaginer également par l'opposition
la minorité municipale étaient présentes
lors de ce conseil d'installation dix
adjoints ont été désignés nous avons une
proposition qui se cale sur le nombre
maximum d'adjoint je pense que nous
aurions pu faire un effort et avec huit
adjoints dans la mesure où il ya
également six conseillers municipaux
délégués qui sont désignés de faire un
travail efficace et ça aurait été un
signe donné à la population
il ya des gens qui ont basculé dans la
précarité ou qui vont basculer dans la
précarité et je pense que les communes
ont un rôle à jouer
pour soutenir les familles les jeunes
les étudiants qui vont souffrir de cette
crise
durant ce conseil d'installation les
élus ont observé une minute de silence
en hommage aux victimes du coc vite 19
derniers conseils d'installation prévu à
saint quentin en yvelines ce jeudi soir
à magny les hameaux et jean michel
fourgous qui est notre invité ce
week-end dans un nouveau numéro du club
de la presse sur tv 60 18 7 ans en
collaboration avec nos confrères de lfm
marmite fm toutes les nouvelles et la
gazette saint quentin en yvelines
le maire d'elancourt et président de
saint quentin en yvelines sera notamment
interrogé sur la situation politique au
sein de l'agglomération et la question
est d'une alliance possible à trappes
entre othman nasri et guy malandain
arrivées respectivement deuxième et
troisième le 15 mars dernier il se
murmure qu'une union serait envisagée
afin de faire barrage à ali rabais qui
s'est classé lui en tête avec une
confortable avance
qu'en pense le président de saint
quentin en yvelines écoutez je sais que
les deux équipes donc mal en hanescu
monde et proximité on lève dans la
campagne où j'ai vu sur même les thèmes
de campagne bon eh bien moi je travaille
dessus malandain si la passion ça se
passe bien et notionnel nice et paris
nantes déjà en à certains niveaux
d'expérience de respect de respect est
encore temps à les retravailler ensemble
on la mecque d'édifiantes donc ils ont
un respect mutuel ils ont les équipes
outils à une grande proximité rap a
besoin d'une équipe sérieux une équipe
rassemblée au delà des partis au delà
des étiquettes beauce droite sens
pratique
je pense qu'il faut un large
rassemblement de contre une union il
faut les listes d'union
voilà il faut surtout enlever les gens
qui divise ce qui n'est qu'une stratégie
de division saas franchement vos examens
n'est pas client à la génération on a vu
quand on est tous suit la quête et du
travail qu'on peut produire tous en par
rapport à des gens qu'on dit des jeux de
monter les uns contre les autres
ça c'est vraiment une contre performance
dans un parc et l'organisation nous
vraiment nous n'est pas demandeur on a
la chance que ça contenir
deuxième tour des élections municipales
prévues pour rappel le 28 juin prochain
et à buc le maire sortant ne se
présentera pas finalement arrivé en
troisième position au premier tour jean
marc le rudulier jette l'épongé est la
crise sanitaire a donné le temps de la
réflexion pour l'élu en poste depuis
au deuxième tour il seront donc deux
candidats juliette espinos ancienne
adjointe en ballottage favorable face à
stéphane grasset et jean-marc le
rudulier a décidé de ne donner aucune
consigne de vote pour le scrutin
c'est un courant baptisé en commun une
association créée par 46 députés de la
majorité la république en marche à
l'assemblée nationale l objectif peser
sur les décisions qui vont être prises
jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat et aller
vers plus de politique solidaire et
écologique
parmi ces parlementaires on retrouve
didier baichère le député des yvelines
l'entretien est menée par nicolas landry
didier baichère bonjour bonjour député
de la première circonscription des
yvelines vous venez de rejoindre
l'association en commun donc c'est une
association au sein du groupe la
république en marche à l'assemblée
nationale qu'est ce qui vous a poussé à
rejoindre cette association de 46
parlementaire on est même 60 maintenant
c'est une aventure intéressante avec les
collègues
lefrançois qui était vice président de
l'assemblée nationale bernard a
compliqué la la présidence de la la
commission du développement durable à
l'assemblée nationale on avait envie à
un moment donné prendre ce temps après
cette crise de pouvoir réorganiser le
débat de qualité dans la majorité puis
essayer d'infléchir le plus possible de
peser en tout cas sur des sujets des
politiques de solidarité sur sur la
transition écologique en particulier et
sur les sujets d'inclusion économique
moi qui me tiennent à coeur la
particulièrement et on voit
malheureusement dans cette année
difficile que c'est toujours les plus
fragiles qui se retrouvent va les
premiers à être en plus en plus grande
difficulté
donc c'est une volonté pour nous
d'organiser le débat et d'être force de
proposition dans les deux ans qui est
devant nous et qui sont deux années je
pense particulière parce
qu'effectivement on est dans cette
situation après une pandémie que
personne évidemment d'aller vous tenir
et qui a des conséquences sur les
économies considérables
qu'est ce que vous attendez la fin du
quinquennat et notamment des décisions
qui vont être prises par le président de
la république et le gouvernement
on a devant nous un plan de regonfler
dantesques et mettre en place il va y
avoir évidemment des conséquences en
matière d'emploi qui sont difficiles qui
sont devant nous moi je vois déjà dans
la circonscription ne serait ce que pour
les apprentis les jeunes qui ont des
stages à faire on voit la difficulté à
mobiliser les entreprises et ce que nous
défendrons à travers en commun c'est
aussi la nécessité à un moment donné de
mettre en place des contre parties
moi je suis très fier qu'on ait investi
110 milliards d'euros pour sauver
l'économie française mais il faut à un
moment donné qui ait des contreparties
que les entreprises quand elles ont reçu
des aides de l'état elles puissent
s'engager sur le volume d'apprentis
qu'elles vont continuer à prendre sur le
volume d'emplois qu'elles vont préserver
malgré la situation de crise on peut pas
toucher 110 milliards d'euros de primes
de l'état d'en payer avec l'impôt des
françaises et des français sans qu'il
ait jamais aucune contrepartie je pense
qu'on peut simplement
et moi je le vois dans le travail qu'on
fait dans les yvelines avec la chambre
de commerce avec le medef et la cgpme
quant au mois de juin on avait signé
avec je viens de normandie cette charte
les entreprises inclusive on peut en
travaillant sur les territoires
rassembler les entreprises aidées
évidemment parce qu'il faut aider et
heureusement que nous avons aidé dans
cette période compliquée mais il faut
aussi qu'ils essaient contrepartie pour
que nos entreprises s'engagent sur la
dimension sociale sur le développement
des compétences pour que les salariés
aussi me trouvent leur place
correctement dans le développement de
leurs avoirs de leurs trouvailles
un dernier mot didier baichère sur deux
secteurs phares du territoire saint
quentinois l'aéronautique et
l'automobile deux secteurs qui sont
frappés un parent par ce choc économique
le président de la république a présenté
un plan de relance pour l'automobile il
ya un plan de relance aussi qui est
prévu pour l'aéronautique au mans
justement faire redresser ces deux
secteurs d'activités là on est en france
sur deux secteurs d'activité
l'automobile et l'aéronautique
que vous soulignez et qui effectivement
dans les yvelines sont extrêmement
présents qui sont extrêmement important
parce que si je prends si je prends que
l'automobile c'est plus de 250 mille
salariés et même si je prends la
totalité des sous traitants sur
l'automobile on est à plus de quatre
cent mille emplois directs en france a
donc cédé secteur d'activité qui qui
sont vraiment vitaux donc c'est un peu
l'idée du plan des 2 8 milliards d'euros
qui a été présenté par le président de
la république
moi je mettrais pas forcément exactement
sur le même plan l'automobile et
l'aéronautique je pense que la crise de
l'aéronautique elle et elle avait
démarré avant locaux vides
j'aurais bien pour l'automobile c'est
plutôt un choc parce qu'il ya un arrêt
il ya un arrêt de la production il y en
a un arrêt des commandes donc on va
aussi relancer cette patience de
l'automobile à travers l'augmentation du
bonus écologique
et puis c'est aussi l'occasion et moi
c'est quand je parle de contrepartie et
ce pour quoi on a créé cette association
en commun de réflexion sait aussi que
dans les contreparties
il faut que cette crypte servent à
accompagner la transformation du secteur
industriel je sois l'aéronautique ou
l'automobile
et c'est très clair dans les
milliardaires qui va y avoir une
transformation vers l'électrique la
nécessité par exemple de renault d'aller
rejoindre ses fameuses airbus des
batteries que que nous montons en europe
avec les constructeurs allemands donc il
ya vraiment une incitation très forte du
gouvernement à ce qui est des
contreparties pour transformer cette
industrie de manière durable et donc
inventé aussi les métiers de demain pour
que les salariés qui peut-être sont en
difficulté aujourd'hui puissent avoir un
accompagnement vers ces métiers de
demain dans le secteur de l'automobile
merci didier baichère député de la
première circonscription des yvelines
culture avec ce geste de solidarité
désormais possible face aux nombreuses
annulations cette saison au théâtre
national de saint quentin en yvelines
beaucoup de spectateurs ont souhaité
refuser le remboursement de leurs
billets et en faire don au site
la scène nationale ouvre cette
possibilité à tous ceux qui le
souhaitent l'intégralité des dons sera
affectée pour les publics saint
quentinois dans le champ social pour
faire don de votre billet vous avez
jusqu'au 7 novembre pour vous manifester
par mail un reçu fiscal sera délivrée
pour bénéficier d'une réduction d'impôt
égale à 66 % du
montant du billet la culture c'est
effectivement l'une des activités qui
n'a pas encore repris avec l'épidémie de
coronavirus festival annulé date
reportée à maisons-laffitte on a choisi
tout de même de proposer au public une
autre formule une édition digitale du
célèbre jazz festival l ancienne église
de la commune est depuis hier devenu
lieu de tournage et d'enregistrement
mélanie poker
[Musique]
auxerre aussi
fait revivre le jazz et la culture
malgré tout pour sa 16e édition le
festival de maisons laffitte a dû se
réinventer
les concerts seront diffusées sur
internet pas de public pas de live je ne
veux pas fonctionné dans le monde
il ya tellement de gens qui ont des vies
très très dur depuis qu'il ya ça je peut
que fonctionner dans dans le bonheur
d'avoir été invité et des de pouvoir
faire ma musique est que ce qu'il
regarde on va pas entendre leurs
applaudissements
[Musique]
j'aime vraiment ça m'avait beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup manqué bah
déjà de voir du monde
et puis jouer ensemble parce que c'est
c'est sympa de bosser tout seul mais
deux mois c'est long quand même sans
jouer avec des gens la programmation a
aussi dû être remanié frontières fermées
oblige les artistes sont principalement
issus de la scène française
sept groupes ont répondu à l'appel de
l'organisation et les retours étaient
tellement enthousiaste et généralement
de solidarité on retrouve ce à dire que
tout le monde a eu envie immédiatement
dès que j'ai proposé ça donc ça donc
c'est parti comme ça au départ ce soient
des partenaires institutionnels comme la
région ile-de-france où la mairie de
maisons laffitte où les partenaires
professionnels comme la sacem l'adami le
fcm ou bien des partenaires privés des
mécènes locaux aussi ils ont répondu
présent à l'appel des enregistrements
que le public pourra savourer
gratuitement du 12 au 21 juin sur le
site du festival et les réseaux sociaux
le plus dur sera de ne pas vraiment les
applaudir et puis avant de vous laisser
c'est un rendez vous traditionnel de la
bonne humeur la fête des voisins est
reporté au 18 septembre mais pas de
panique pour la date initiale prévue
demain vendredi il vous est proposé tout
de même de faire une fête des voisins au
balcon et aux fenêtres afin de respecter
la distanciation social pour l'organiser
c'est très simple un kit de
communication est téléchargeable via le
lien qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité très belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]